more than 10 million americans have been
infected with covet 19 since this
pandemic began
and that includes more than one million
new cases since the end of october
that is the worst stretch of infection
so far in this country
our lead national correspondent david
bagno is in detroit with more on the
story
david good morning to you we know the
midwest is getting hammered by this
virus right now
sure is good morning from the banks of
the detroit river my friend
listen nearly half of all the cases in
the united states are right here in the
midwest
in fact in michigan their new
coronavirus cases the rate of new cases
has soared 300 percent in the last four
weeks
now listen it's accelerating around the
country the case count but it's notable
that hospitalizations
are at levels we haven't seen since july
across the u.s hospitalizations due to
coronavirus
are close to record highs cases are on
the rise
in 46 states and experts warn the worst
is yet to come on sunday utah's
republican governor introduced a
statewide mass mandate
for the very first time pointing to
overcrowding
in utah's hospitals they are really at
the brink of not being able to take any
more people and
in the overflow mode particularly in our
intensive care units
in el paso texas one in every five
coronavirus tests is coming back
positive
and icu's are at capacity at this
funeral home
one room is filled with bodies the home
says it has 220 people awaiting burial
or cremation
and that most of them died from
coronavirus a lot of families that have
had a loved one pass away from covid
they're all worried that they may be
next
the united states is now averaging over
950 deaths
every day and the virus continues to
claim the lives of people like austin
tanner
he was 18 years old from melvindale
michigan
he died on october 27th we spoke to his
mother carrie
tell me just what's going through your
mind right now
pain loss
unbelievable it's horrible i feel empty
lost and alone without him kerry says
she doesn't know where
or how her son caught the virus she says
he only left the house to go to church
and to a support group for his anxiety
austin had autism
and kerry says he was terrified about
catching the virus
because he was overweight has nothing to
do with this
disease this virus whatever it is
this this plague that is taking
over our country the world
then his weight had nothing to do with
it it is this
horrible horrible virus that is
attacking people
and it's not prejudice
and we'll attack anyone
carrie was telling us how much the
community loves austin she said her
peers had elected him
homecoming king in high school and when
austin died the
family was still in quarantine so the
community went to their home
and actually held a vigil for austin in
the family's front yard
tony david you do such a job of
reminding us of the human toll of all
this thank you very much